[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa este es el
programa de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
vamos primero a sudamérica a colombia
porque la corte constitucional el máximo
tribunal del país despenalizó el aborto
hasta la semana 24 de gestación el giro
más amplio sobre la interrupción del
embarazo en la región
y luego vamos a eeuu que arremetió con
sanciones en contra de rusia y sus
élites por la invasión a ucrania sin
embargo algunos países de la región que
durante décadas han tenido vínculos
económicos o ideológicos con el kremlin
han evitado condenar sus acciones les
contamos cuáles
y terminamos en california porque una
comunidad nativa ha declarado el estado
de emergencia por los asesinatos y
desapariciones de sus mujeres que son
tres veces superiores a los de las
blancas
y comenzamos en colombia la corte
suprema de justicia anunció que las
mujeres podrán acceder al aborto hasta
la semana 24 de gestación y después de
ese tiempo solo podrán hacerlo a través
de las tres causales que estaban
permitidas anteriormente en caso de
violación malformación del feto o
peligro para la vida de la madre con
esta decisión colombia se convirtió en
el país de américa latina más a la
vanguardia en materia de derechos para
las mujeres pero la medida generó debate
tanto entre la comunidad médica como
entre los sectores conservadores sin
embargo su despenalización tendrá
impacto en la cifra de muertes de
mujeres en abortos clandestinos como nos
da cuenta a mal benotman en el siguiente
informe
la victoria para los derechos de las
mujeres en américa la china en colombia
desde el 21 de febrero el aborto hasta
la semana 24 de gestación ya no es un
delito la corte constitucional optó por
despenalizar lo tomando en cuenta
estudios científicos que indican la
ausencia de dolor del feto hasta esta
etapa del embarazo este plazo se explica
por las grandes desigualdades del
sistema de salud en la nación
suramericana que nos ha dicho la corte
que las mujeres hasta la semana 24
pueden interrumpir la gestación por sus
propias razones y aquí es donde yo
quisiera enfatizar en la trascendencia
de la decisión porque eso reconoce la
autonomía de las mujeres en de una
manera significativa durante un periodo
importante de la gestación y eso es lo
que nos va a permitir con pedagogía que
la mayoría de las mujeres se sientan
tranquilas y sin temor de buscar ayuda
de manera temprana y que logremos lo que
se ha logrado en muchas partes del mundo
y es que la mayoría de los abortos
ocurren tempranamente durante el
embarazo pero que las mujeres más
vulnerables que no alcanzan a abortar
tempranamente también sean acogidas por
el sistema de salud y sean tratadas con
dignidad y con igualdad hasta entonces
en colombia el aborto se castigaba con
una pena de prisión por hasta cuatro
años y medio excepto bajo tres
excepciones malformación del feto
peligro para la vida de la madre o
violación las organizaciones feministas
y de derechos humanos llevaban años
denunciando el que consideran es un
doble sistema una sociedad en la que las
mujeres ricas abortan en clínicas
privadas mientras que las mujeres de las
zonas rurales de los barrios pobres o
las mujeres afectadas por el conflicto
armado lo hacen en condiciones precarias
y peligrosas en este país
tradicionalmente católico la decisión de
la corte provocó un debate y la
indignación de los sectores de derecha
incluso en voz del presidente iván duque
yo creo que aquí realmente estamos ante
una decisión que atañe a toda la
sociedad colombiana y cinco personas no
pueden
plantearle a una nación algo tan atroz
como permitir que se interrumpa una vida
hasta los seis meses de gestación la
despenalización es sólo un primer paso
ahora al congreso y al poder ejecutivo
les corresponde regular el derecho al
aborto y aplicar una política pública al
respecto por lo tanto es probable que la
lucha de las mujeres no haya terminado
el presidente de eeuu joe biden aseguró
que no enviará tropas a ucrania para
responder a la invasión rusa pero
anunció una serie de sanciones
económicas en contra del kremlin como
castigo y es que en medio de un coro de
condenas de los líderes occidentales
algunas naciones de américa anunciaron
su apoyo al presidente ruso vladimir
putin desde estados que tienen negocios
con rusia hasta adversarios de larga
data de eeuu como nos cuenta marina
sardina el presidente argentino pidió
retomar el diálogo lamento profundamente
la escalada bélica que conocemos a
partir de la situación generada en
ucrania el diálogo y respeto a la
soberanía la integridad territorial
de los estados y a los derechos humanos
garantizan soluciones justas y duraderas
a los conflictos en chile y perú los
nuevos mandatarios de izquierda también
apelaron a la paz
rusia ha optado por la guerra como medio
para resolver conflictos desde chile
condenamos la invasión a ucrania la
violación de su soberanía y el uso
ilegítimo de la fuerza nuestra
solidaridad estará con las víctimas y
nuestros humildes esfuerzos con la paz
creo importante
llamar a la unidad de los pueblos y en
el mundo
que los conflictos se desarrollen en el
marco
diplomático
que no se inviertan en balas que nos
inviertan en municiones desde méjico
amplio nombro las posibles consecuencias
económicas derivadas del conflicto
ruso-ucraniano nos vamos a seguir
conduciendo
promoviendo que haya diálogo
qué
no se utilice la fuerza que no haya
invasión no estamos
a favor de ninguna guerra el espectro
político conservador de la región
criticó la invasión de las tropas rusas
a ucrania colombia rechaza
categóricamente el ataque premeditado
injustificado que se ha perpetrado
contra el pueblo ucraniano por parte de
rusia que no sólo atenta contra la
soberanía sino amenaza a la paz mundial
estoy totalmente comprometido con el
esfuerzo de proteger y ayudar a los
brasileños que se encuentran en ucrania
ecuador cree en el multilateralismo
y está dispuesto a
respetar
y apoyar las decisiones que tome el
consejo de seguridad
de las naciones unidas por su parte los
aliados en la región del mandatario ruso
vladimir putin cuba nicaragua o
venezuela llevan varios días expresando
su apoyo a moscú
seguimos en eeuu en un remoto tramo de
la costa pacífica ubicado en el norte de
california allí un pueblo nativo ha
declarado el estado de emergencia en
medio de una creciente crisis de
asesinatos y desapariciones de mujeres
el problema no se limita a esa zona pero
un reciente repunte de casos llevó al
pueblo europe a tomar acciones con la
ayuda de una ong que está trabajando
para establecer la primera base de datos
de estas desapariciones en ese estado
estadounidense albiol y realmente lo que
siento es que desde el principio la
deberían haber buscado más bigger search
está desaparecida desde octubre graduada
de la universidad y bailarina
tradicional descendiente de tres
comunidades indígenas nativas emily
risling de 33 años también es madre de
dos
es realmente difícil cuando tienes a los
nietos y que tu nieto te pregunte abuelo
puedes llevarme al río y podemos buscar
a mi mamá que le respondes
y él te dice qué pasa si no lo
encontramos
en los meses anteriores a su
desaparición regling había estado
luchando con su salud mental se le vio
por última vez caminando por un puente
en una zona remota de la reserva de rock
en el norte de california en esta zona
casi todo el mundo conoce a alguien que
desapareció risling es una de las cinco
mujeres indígenas que han desaparecido
en los últimos 18 meses pero un informe
publicado este año por un grupo de
observación pública reveló que el
verdadero número es desconocido debido a
los problemas se denuncia la
desconfianza de las fuerzas del orden en
los conflictos jurisdiccionales
hay un laberinto de jurisdicciones de
políticas de procedimientos de quien
investiga que trabaje con una familia
durante tres días no se pudo conseguir
que nadie investigara la violación
porque el condado el estado y la policía
tribal no podían determinar quién tenía
jurisdicción el caso de risling ilustra
algunos de estos desafíos perteneciente
a la tribu hope abel y se le da por
desaparecida en la hierba de la tribu y
europa
la geografía de la reserva
definitivamente ha presentado desafíos a
la aplicación de la ley específicamente
dentro de este caso es que las mujeres
nativas se enfrentan a tasas de
homicidio casi tres veces superiores a
la de las mujeres blancas el abuso de
drogas y la violencia doméstica son
también desproporcionadamente altos
activistas dicen que estos casos se han
descuidado durante décadas
la comunidad como gobierno se está
frustrando y están cansados de que
parezca que los pueblos nativos no
reciben la atención que ven con otros
casos de desaparición a nivel local y en
todo el país y además y 62 en costa con
la tribu euro que está trabajando para
crear la primera base de datos de estos
casos en california
varios estados se están ocupando de la
crisis con más estudios sobre el
problema y mayor financiación hablemos
de deportes de una larga batalla legal
de la selección femenina de fútbol de
estados unidos que logró un acuerdo
histórico con la federación de fútbol de
la unión
y yo el soccer pagará a las jugadoras 22
millones de dólares el organismo también
se comprometió a igualar los salarios
respecto a la selección nacional
masculina cuando negoció en su contrato
fue un partido largo pero después de
seis años la selección nacional femenina
de eeuu ha ganado la federación de
fútbol estadounidense de pagar a 22
millones de dólares distribuidos como
las jugadoras lo considera inconveniente
y como lo apruebe la corte y prometió
salarios iguales para mujeres y hombres
la próxima vez que inicien negociaciones
de contrato eres de wayne es una gran
victoria para nosotras para el deporte
femenino para las mujeres en general es
un momento que todos podemos celebrar
ahora en 2020 un tribunal de california
desestimó el reclamo del equipo femenino
porque ganaban menos que los hombres por
el contrario descubrió que ganaban más
en conjunto y por partido desde 2015 en
el momento las mujeres ganaron dos copas
del mundo y lograron negociar salarios
más altos que antes mientras tanto la
selección masculina que tiene bonos más
grandes por juego pero sin salario anual
tuvo un desempeño terrible
sin poder siquiera clasificar a la copa
del mundo si las mujeres hubieran estado
en el modelo de los hombres durante este
periodo habrían ganado mucho más no está
claro cómo será exactamente la igualdad
salarial cuando ambos equipos nacionales
se sienten a negociar pero la jugadora
estrella megan rapinoe está convencida
que significará un futuro más brillante
para las mujeres
la nueva generación de jugadores podrá
simplemente jugar y con eso viene ya
sabes probablemente sean mucho mejores
que nosotras las tres caras de call you
soccer se une a los órganos de gobierno
del reino unido brasil australia e
irlanda que también se han comprometido
a igualar los salarios para sus equipos
femeninos y finalizamos esta emisión de
aquí américa con un estreno musical que
nos llega desde cuba se trata del nuevo
sencillo del artista y estilista afro
cubano roberto álvarez titulado cabello
bello
porque mi cabello
[Música]
conocido en el mundo musical como robe
el niño su música se ha convertido en un
símbolo de identidad con esta canción
reivindica la belleza del cabello afro y
su significado histórico gracias por
acompañarnos en esta emisión de asia
américa sigan viendo france24 kansas
disímiles texturas crece buscando el
cielo buscando la cintura y se metió en
la cabeza esta gente que en mi piel es
malo como si mi pelo fuera un
delincuente
r efe